This evening, Salat-ul-Ishaa will be at
8:45.
Salat-ul-Ishaa this evening, tonight,
will be at 8:45.
[Arabic recitation]
yesterday morning in our introduction
to the rulings on al-masah alal
khuffain,
wiping over
the footwear. Yesterday,
I spoke about the general Sunnah
of how the Prophet, our messenger,
sallallahu alayhi wasallam,
would wipe over his
footwear
and how the companions, radiyallahu
anhu, did that.
Now, we're going to take a peek into the
technical side,
which is we're going to look at what is
the bare minimum, what is the maximum,
and what are some of the specifics.
However,
keep in mind, if you paid attention very
well yesterday,
which I think were about 10 minutes,
we
took 99%
of what we're going to
be reading now.
And if you paid good attention
yesterday,
then you should be in a very good
position to easily understand the rest
of what we're going to discuss in this
chapter.
There are few of conditions. Just as
we've mentioned before, every act of
worship has conditions and pillars.
Every act of worship. Every act of
If that's the
if that is the case,
then what are the conditions
for wiping over a person's footwear?
The author tells us,
The first thing
is that in order for you to wipe over
your footwear,
socks, shoes,
leather socks, whatever it is,
you have to have put these on initially
having made full wudu and washed your
feet.
So, there is no such thing as wiping
over your socks or your footwear and
then putting on a different pair of
socks or footwear. That doesn't exist.
You will only have put that particular
pair of socks or shoes on that you're
going to wipe over.
You put them on
after having made wudu fully and washed
your feet.
You were in a state of full wudu,
then you put on your
leather socks.
When we say full wudu, I don't want you
to imagine that wiping over the footwear
is somehow lesser. It's not. It's the
same reward,
same full wudu, right?
It's just that in order for that to
count, you have to have put them on
in
a state of wudu.
yesterday.
[Silence]
We mentioned this yesterday. Al-Mughirah
ibn Shu'bah,
an interesting man, Al-Mughirah ibn
Shu'bah.
Did you know that Al-Mughirah ibn
Shu'bah
was a bandit and a killer before Islam?
He was a terror for any traveler that
went out in his direction. He was known
by name.
And Al-Mughirah ibn Shu'bah was an
absolute nightmare.
He was a bandit, qatta' tariq.
You and yours, you're traveling
unbeknownst to you,
you know, hee-hawing or whatever, and
then Al-Mughirah ibn Shu'bah pops out
and you have a very bad day.
Al-Mughirah ibn Shu'bah actually
did one last job
before he became Muslim. And this shows
you
the mentality
of people before Islam.
And this is why Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala teaches us.
And so,
that one last job, he
made quite a bit of money, and then he
came and accepted Islam.
The Prophet Sallallahu alayhi wasallam
heard about that.
And so, he said,
"Do not attempt to give us any of that
money that you took."
Right? We will not accept any of that
money from you.
Al-Mughirah ibn Shu'bah accepted Islam,
and he then became one of the best
companions in all of the Prophet
Sallallahu alayhi wasallam's companions.
And he was very skilled in the
avenues of war.
This was his language.
And so, he was an official guard of the
Prophet Sallallahu alayhi wasallam,
especially in the negotiations of
al-Hudaybiyyah.
Also, al-Mughirah ibn Shu'bah
radiyallahu anhu
was a servant, as we see here, of the
Prophet Sallallahu alayhi wasallam. He
used to travel with him often.
And he is one of the great martyrs of
Islam. Al-Mughirah ibn Shu'bah
radiyallahu anhu,
he says, "I was with the Prophet
Sallallahu alayhi wasallam one evening
as we were traveling.
And so, I poured the water for his wudu.
So, he went, used the restroom, you
know, he relieved himself, he came back,
and al-Mughirah ibn Shu'bah is pouring
the
water for him to make wudu."
He says, "And so, he
washed his face and his arms
and he wiped over his head and then I
went to take off his
khuffain.
His leather
footwear.
And he said to me, "Dahuma, leave them."
Fainni adkhaltuhuma ya'ni
adkhaltu qadamayya. Fainni adkhaltuhuma
tahiratayni.
Leave them for I put my feet into those
in a state of wudu.
And so, al-Mughirah says he then
proceeded to wipe over them.
Now, why does
the Sheikh keep saying footwear? Why
doesn't he just say leather socks?
This is an interesting thing.
When it comes to
what we wipe over,
it doesn't matter what it is. The
material doesn't matter in the correct
opinion. It doesn't matter if it is
shoes, if it is leather, doesn't matter
if it's thin, doesn't matter if it is
sheen, if you can see through it,
doesn't matter if it's thick, doesn't
matter if you wear it independently or
wear it with shoes.
Anything that you wear over your feet
is permissible to wipe over with a few
conditions that we will get to.
Now,
the most common thing that the Prophet
sallallahu alayhi wasallam and the
companions would wear is al-khuffain.
Al-khuff.
And al-khuff
is
a leather
shoe. It's not a leather sock.
It is a leather shoe.
It's made out of hard
leather, usually lamb or steer hide that
has been tanned and
hardened.
And so, when you look at the earlier
fuqaha,
Abu Hanifah rahimahullah, Malik,
Shafi, when they when they identify the
type or describe
the type of khuff that the prophet would
wear, sallallahu alayhi wasallam, they
have different descriptions of it. They
say,
"It's only considered to be a khuff if
it stands on its own."
Meaning, when you take it off, it stands
boots. They stand up on their own.
Right? Or you have to be able to walk in
them without shoes for it to be
considered a khuff.
Or you have to be able to walk such and
such distance in them.
Now, because of the weak translation of
leather sock,
in the West, we wear socks with shoes.
Right? We don't walk around outside with
just socks on.
So,
some people in in some madhhab,
you can only wipe over leather
khuff. It has to be that.
And so, the idea then is, "Well, let's
design a leather sock." And the
translation comes as leather socks.
And so, they start producing this
leather sock. It's very fine, thin
leather,
usually made out of lambskin.
Most of them are just really pleather,
just plastic leather, fake leather. It's
not real leather.
And
you put it on and, you know, you you
wear them with shoes. And this is so
that we can wipe over them. You go to
what we call a Muslim store or an
Islamic store. We've all seen them,
right? And it'll be this very soft
leather and you put them on and they
usually have a zipper and that has no
relation to the khuff that was worn in
the prophet's time, sallallahu alaihi
wasallam.
That is more
appropriate
to have come from the region of Persia.
And is that bad? No. Is there anything
wrong with that? Absolutely not. Can you
wipe over them? Yes.
But do you have to particularly go out
and find those and buy them so that you
can now practice the sunnah of wiping
over your socks or shoes? No.
And if that were your intention, you
would have failed miserably because that
is not in any way related to the khuff
that were was worn in the prophet's
time, sallallahu alaihi wasallam. The
khuff is very hard leather.
And leather
used to be take the place of most
plastics today.
Leather is very hard and it has the
potential to be extremely hard. Most
soles until about 60 years ago on all
shoes were made out of leather, leather
soles. And even shields and armor
that were designed to repel sword
strikes and light
arrow hand hand bow
strike were made out of of thick
steerhide and leather. So, leather took
the place of most of what we use today
as plastic, right? Arguably much better
than plastics are.
so, that is enough for today.